I love Leonarda country I saw him for
the first time in the movie Titanic he
was just so cute and objective and I'm
pretty sure I am not the only one who
fell in their way when i watch the
inception and you know the great gatsby
oh my god I fell in love with him again
so you probably understand how shocked I
was when I saw these photos on Google
it's really hard to believe that they
are the same person
so what makes difference that's the
topic we're gonna into this today
clothing clothing matters holding is
worth your thousand words it is a very
effective nonverbal communication tool
for two reasons first it affects how
other people perceive you and behave
towards you there are a lot of research
to prove this for example if you wear a
suit and then cross the street again
subtracting 13.5 times as many people
will follow you as when users wear your
shirt or trousers worship and trousers
also during negotiations people in
offices are more likely to have a
profitable deal than people in sweaters
and secondly more importantly it affects
how you think of yourself your
self-confidence we just get our power
course aim is purpose like us for women
words for men
it helped us feel the power and
confidence and in fact coding can give
you the same effect it turns out they're
people in super your clothing or more
confident mentally and physically so
find your own superhero coding they
speak you will and also make you feel
very confident
clean song look it feel good to good and
present well how are we going to do this
without aim framework audience intent
and message and edit will introduce how
you can connect with the audience
through your encoding thank you now
before I start when was the last time
you walk into a room and the first thing
on your mind is gosh I wish I wore
something different I think it's a very
painful experience for those headaches
they have experienced it before and let
me offer you three advice or trick
questions we can ask ourselves not
calling the audience and avoid from
deform happening again the first
question we ask ourselves who are they
and who do you what would be where to
get our thinking let's let me refer you
to a book by a leading image consultants
to read our cube in the console title
the image of leadership in it she
describes five simple levels level of a
business way this takes out order
ambiguity about you know what schedule
smart casual respect former we don't but
what is important is that we can use
this to apply to our everyday business
way so it ranges from the very form of
pallulah tires like what I'm wearing
right now all the way to the Silicon
Valley with my schedule
similar to aprender this way and in
between we have the main content like
Ryan and as active schedule lagina and
we based on these five levels we apply
the plus one minus one framework how it
works so you as you identify what the
audience ways okay
and then you we're one step higher more
formal
okay so that you create a sense of
presence and the sense offer of
executive confidence and then one trick
is that you you should only step down
stress less formal maximum one step only
when they invite you subsequently to a
scheduled event
second question to answer is what do
they expect what do they expect you to
wear specific to your industry to your
role this is a tricky question because
often between specific professions they
are all over on set and unreturned norms
for dress code and but often the easiest
way is ask people to work in those
industries as well
probably in a more is it a easier way is
to actually observe what keeper wear
around us every day and the ten suggest
be the best place to learn take for
example yes I wish Mitch Raymond Lazar
and Peter vendors or teaching the same
class by wearing different attire every
day so but what religions are for me is
actually a ribbon result use of a ball
time a machine really stand out from the
crowd but also as to its credibility as
a public relations expert Polly if you
understand how this view the idea here
is basically we should open our attire
with symbols that triggers emotion in
our audience what I mean by that
take for example if you go for an
interview with a government the best tip
I can give to you is wear a flag key
instantly you're using interviewers will
feel differently they would like you a
reason is because they don't see a flag
thing
what they see this with this I'll hand
over to Ryan to talk about how to
communicate in telematics we volatile
most situations simply meeting the norms
and expectations of your audience is not
enough we also need to consider what you
wear says about you as a person as well
as an organization you may be
representing if you dress in a way
that's not comfortable for you to come
across as inauthentic and create
cynicism this is a picture of me when I
was working at a start-up this summer
and made an effort to try and downplay
the fact that I was an MP
for better for worse what you wear to
the live out where you are the person
there's the obvious straightforward
stuff you want to look well put together
and prepared and wear something that
makes you feel confident as well as
comfortable there's also a lot of
trade-offs that go into these decision
consider when you first go to work at a
company next year you're giving your
first presentation if you want to dress
in a way that establishes your authority
or do you want to come across as a more
relatable peer are you someone who's
more laid-back or more buttoned up and
formal and you want to represent kind of
status quo traditional culture of the
organization or you're someone who's
going to rock the boat and be more
progressive this becomes even more
challenging when you factor in the brand
of a company that you may be
representing so take for example if you
work at a Silicon Valley company and
you're meeting with investment bankers
in New York you put on just your
freshest hoodie and with a company logo
on it or you go out and buy a pair of
cufflinks an effort could kind of fit in
with the expectation you can do it
Zuckerberg did and try and compromise
but the reality is that oftentimes these
two aspects don't overlap completely and
at times they may be in direct conflict
with each other so the first thing you
need to do at a minimum is understand
what it is the brand of a company or
organization or cause that you're
representing is and then you want to
make a conscious decision deciding
whether you want your message the
message your appearance them too along
with that or contrast it at times
emphasizing an aspect of your brand can
be beneficial such as wise with Shane
Smith emphasizing the fact that twice is
an edgy and next-generation news
organization Sheryl Sandberg Khan takes
a different approach and gives a narrow
kind of professionalism that you know
Facebook culture typically is not known
for its kind of a way to say that you
know there's an adult in the room this
can sometimes backfire ending situations
for exactly if you're working at a very
traditional company and come across and
try and impersonate Steve Jobs that can
you
in the authenticity whereas you're
working at the cutting edge company work
on quantum computing and you dress more
like a Salesman that make question how
how credible organization is so how do
you how do you read these challenges
just like you would in preparing the
content for your presentation you want
to have you want to make it explicit
decision about what message you want to
communicate one address with intent and
make sure that everything you wear align
is that visual elements of a
presentation are often most memorable
and leave a lasting impression so the
very least you don't want to leave this
up for interpretation or ambiguity if
you can be consistent with the company
brand you represent that's great if
you're if you're trying if you want you
can also contrast the message but either
way make sure you do so deliberately
with these principles branded will now
talk a little bit more about how to do
this in practice great thank you I'm
going to give you a few key tips for
successful execution of dressing for
communication the first pen plan ahead
of time
now when you plan ahead of time that
doesn't just mean knowing what your
superhero costume is that's important
that's great but it's also looking your
closet making sure it's there picking it
out ironing it's doing all the prep work
you need to do who has moved recently in
the last 18 months everybody in the room
probably or most people I use four times
last 18 months last year when I was
interviewing for the first time I knew
exactly what I wanted to wear I knew it
down to the wire down to the sweater but
guess what it wasn't there I didn't
actually go to the closet take it out
look at it
iron it do all the things I was supposed
to have done and guess what that
affected me during the interview missing
that key piece of clothing missing that
sweater changed the interview from being
great to the interviewer at Apple asked
me why I was wearing a suit jacket
it affected second thing think about
travel this isn't just the former
consultant telling you to pack your bag
a week ahead of time because
about the plane this is things about
every aspect of travel how are you
getting from your house to the place
where you're presenting are you biking
are using the subway are you flying this
all indicates ways in which you may
think about how do you get yourself
there what you should wear when you get
out of bed should you change that the
location versus changing at your home
these are all considerations finally
let's talk about communicating as a team
thinking about how you want to work as a
team weather is everybody's wearing all
black
whether it's communicating by you know
having different styles and being
contrasting all these are these things
you need to think about because two
things could happen potentially you
could be at a completely different level
as your colleague that might not be okay
or maybe you're all wearing the exact
same spin and while that's okay in the
case of a wedding party it may not be
the image you want to present if you're
going to an interview or if you're
presenting as a team so those are just a
few of our key tips but we also want to
talk a little bit about you know what is
breaking the fashion rules really neat
this is Lady Gaga's famous neat drastic
most of you will probably recognize and
you know the day after she wore this a
lot of people said this was a fashion
don't
breaking all the rules but if you think
about the rules that we have discussed
today knowing your audience knowing your
message knowing your intent dressing the
way that makes you feel confident makes
you feel good planning executing and
thinking about every step of the process
I've tasted it pretty well if you think
about these steps as you think about
these tools that we've discussed today I
think you might have this kind of effect
on your audience as well
[Music]